in a few hours lawmakers from both
parties will see classified information
about an FBI informant who spoke to
trump campaign advisers in 2016 reports
say the bureau was investigating a claim
that one of those advisers had ties to
Russia which the bureau was also
investigating for meddling in the
election the president is now calling it
Spygate he says it quote could be one of
the biggest political scandals in
history ed O'Keefe is here with what we
know and don't know about the FBI probe
heed good morning good morning okay
there's a lot of politics and strategy
going on here but can we what is the
central question at the heart of this
first before we get to that well in many
ways the central question is what
exactly is still being investigated and
what are they looking for the president
would like it to be about the
investigators not what they're
investigating and today's meeting is
designed to in essence sort of appease
two of his biggest allies on Capitol
Hill and show them some of what the
Justice Department knows about this
person and then we don't know what
exactly else they might get showed or
what they might ask FBI and the Justice
Department are going to show classified
information about the Russia
investigation and the president's chief
of staff is going to be there to see it
apparently and that's you know and this
keeps going back and forth he arranged
the meeting he was gonna be there he
wasn't gonna be there now he's gonna be
there and that is a departure from the
norm not that we haven't had enough of
those but because usually these are
briefings for senior lawmakers an
administration official like this would
never sit in on a meeting like that and
and there have been objections by
Democrats especially some Republican
senators who say that this whole
arrangement is out of the norm and
shouldn't be going on anyway and the
reason it's out of the norm is not just
that it's a different branch of
government but that the Department of
Justice has an investigation of that
branch of government and so is John
Kelly there is a representative of the
executive branch or of the president
whose team is being investigated and
that's what the Democrats want to know
that's why they're concerned about it
Democrats are in one of the meetings
they weren't always going to be that's
right there was a lot of back-and-forth
yesterday about who exactly would be at
these meetings when they would be held
at one point this gang of eight which is
the speaker the House Minority Leader
the Senate leaders and the leaders of
the intelligence committees we're going
to get a meeting but then we're going to
get it until after the Memorial Day
recess which is a week next week and so
they insisted it had to be today it's
happening this afternoon
he keeps calling it Spygate yeah because
he calls it Spygate doesn't make it so
no and there's there any evidence to
support his claims of an informant there
is nothing in the public record that
suggests that this the spying aspect
that he talks about and frankly buying
on his campaign right and as a football
fan Spygate means something entirely
different to those of us who are not
fans of the New England Patriots I'm
sorry Nora but you know that was about
cheating and then that was Spygate to so
many people he's gin this up in the last
few days well I think it is Concordat
with nothing - exactly and it is
consistent whether it's a good thing or
a bad thing that's in the eye of the
voter but it is consistent with what he
has done to raise doubts about the news
media about James Comey about his
opponents in 2016 and it often works in
his favor if you look at polling that
we've done and others you know the faith
in this investigation and whether or not
he should be cooperating has eroded
especially among Republicans over the
course of this year all right to be
continued for sure thank you good to see
you